hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
in our previous two sessions we
discussed what is correlation
correlation coefficient and types of
correlation
in this session
we'll continue the discussion and try to
understand the difference between
correlation and regression
and discuss it with the help of an
example
so let's discuss the agenda for today's
session
we'll start this tutorial by discussing
what is correlation then we'll move on
to understand types of correlation and
we'll discuss one major type that is
positive and negative correlation
after that we'll move on to what is
regression lines of regression and then
we'll discuss a simple regression model
with its equation
finally we'll move on to excel to
discuss how we can calculate the
regression using an example
so let's begin what is correlation a
correlation is a statistical
relationship between two entities
it measures the extent to which the two
variables are linearly related
in simple words
it is a measurement of strength of
association between the two variables
for example an increase in the price of
commodity is always accompanied by
decrease in demand
the value of the correlation always lies
between minus one to plus one
types of correlation
there are mainly three categories of
correlation
the first one is positive and negative
correlation
the second one is linear correlation and
non-linear correlation and the third one
is simple multiple and partial
correlation
let's discuss positive and negative
correlation
a positive correlation means that a
linear relationship is positive
and the two variables increases or
decreases in the same direction as you
can see from the graph
an example can be as the number of trees
cut down increases the probability of
soil erosion also increases
in the same manner a negative
correlation is just the opposite
the relationship line has a negative
slope as you can see from the graph
and the variables changes in the
opposite direction that is one variable
decreases while the other increases to
understand this an example can be if a
car decreases the speed the time taken
to reach the destination increases
to know more about the types of
correlation you can refer to our
previous videos and you can find the
link in our description now what is
regression
regression analysis like most
multivariate statistics allows you to
infer that there is a relationship
between two or more variables
these relationships are seldom exact
because there is a variation caused by
many variables not just the variables
being studied
in regression analysis there are two
types of variable one is dependent
variable and other is the independent
variable
let's discuss what the both variable
represents a dependent variable is a
variable whose value is influenced or to
be predicted
the dependent variable is often denoted
by y and is also known as a predicted
variable
whereas independent variable which is
denoted by x is a variable which
influences the value or is used for
prediction
the independent variable is also known
as a predictor variable
the line of regression the regression
line is a line which is used to describe
the behavior of a set of data
in other words it gives the best trend
of the given data regression lines are
useful in forecasting procedures its
purpose is to describe the
interrelationship between the dependent
variable and independent variable
the regression equation of y and x
describes the change in the value of y
for given changes in the value of x and
vice versa
in the regression line equation x and y
are the variables of interest in our
data with y the unknown or dependent
variable and x the known or the
independent variable
let's discuss the two key terms in this
graph the first one is slope
slope is the ratio of the vertical and
horizontal distances between the two
points on a line
and you can see y-intercept which is the
coordinate of the point at which the
curve intersects an axis there are some
assumptions we take to create the
regression model the first one is the
dependent variable is assumed to be
normally distributed
the values of the dependent variable are
statistically independent
this means that when we select the
sample of a particular x it does not
depend on any other value of y
and that third one is error values of
statistically independent
now let's discuss a simple regression
model
a simple regression model is used to
depict a relationship between variables
which are proportional to each other
meaning the dependent variable increases
decreases with the independent variable
the equation of a simple regression
model is y is equal to b naught plus b 1
x plus e
where y is dependent variable x is
independent variable b naught and b 1
represents y intercept and the slope of
the line respectively and e is the error
variable
now let's move on to excel to calculate
the regression coefficient of a given
data we are on our excel workbook
in front of us we have the data of
temperature of the day and sales of the
ice cream on that day
let's try to understand the regression
analysis and summary output using this
data
so the first step is to
go to the data tab and select data
analysis
then select regression and click ok
we'll get this table
select the y range as ice cream sales
this y range is predictable variable
also called as dependent variable
for the input x range
select the temperature in degree celsius
this is the explanatory variable also
called as independent variable
one thing you should keep in mind
is that both the x and y column must be
adjacent to each other
we have the label so we'll check the
label
and we'll select the output range
from g5
check the residuals and click ok
excel produces the following output
let's analyze some key data
we got the ask value to be 0.9676
which is very good
this shows that 96 percent of the
variation in ice cream sales is
explained by the temperature of the day
closer to the one the better the
regression line fits the data
now let's move little more and analyze
this coefficient
if you look at the coefficient you will
get the equation of the regression line
in our case
it is minus
176.33 plus 27.68 into temperature of
the day
substituting the temperature of the day
for any given day we can find the sales
of the ice cream
with our discussion we can conclude that
there is a big difference between the
correlation and regression although
these are studied together
correlation is used to study whether the
variables under study are correlated
whereas
regression is used to establish the
functional relationship between the two
variables
the equation of the regression line is a
form
y is equal to f x plus
c correlation is used to establish the
strength of the association between the
two variables that are being studied
whereas regression is used to make the
future projections on the any given
event
so with this we have come to an end to
this tutorial
thank you all for watching this session
we hope you enjoyed it
if you have any questions feel free to
put them in the comment section of this
video thank you again and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here